Speaker 1: Also at the Vision 24 National
Conservative Forum was Nikki Haley,
2024 Republican presidential
wannabe. She didn't make any sense.
She actually seems completely unable or unwilling
to explain why she's running and to really I mean,
I don't if she is auditioning to be Trump's
VP, that I understand. If she is auditioning to
become the next Tulsi Wright, who gets a gig on
Fox News and, you know, a podcast or something,
then maybe it makes sense. But she seems visibly
confused by every question. Here she is saying,
Our kids must say the Pledge of Allegiance.
Speaker 3:
Our kids need to be saying the Pledge of
Allegiance when they start their day so
that they know to love America.
Speaker 1: Aha. Nikki Haley,
who is an advocate of freedom and liberty, is
demanding that children be forced to recite a
pledge of allegiance to the flag. And that will
make them love America. Freedom to be forced by
schools to say the Pledge of Allegiance. Huh. It's
kind of kind of interesting. Doesn't really make a
lot of sense, does it? Nikki Haley claims that 90%
of American children are now under critical race
theory. They're under it. I think she means
under the regime of it or something. Listen
to this. What would you have to say about the
wokeism that's infiltrating the school systems?
Speaker 3: 90% of our American kids
are now under critical race theory.
Speaker 1: They used to be over
it. Then they were alongside it,
and now they are crushed beneath its weight.
Speaker 3: That means if a little girl goes
into kindergarten, if she's white, you're
telling her she's bad. If she's brown or black,
you're telling her she's never going to be good
enough and she's always going to be a victim.
Speaker 1: I missed that kindergarten class. I
would like to speak to the kindergarten teacher
that is teaching that.
Speaker 3: And that's
wrong. The idea that we are doing.
Speaker 1: It's also not happening.
Speaker 3: ID'ing our children based on
race, based on religion, based on all of
these things. That's not what we're supposed
to happen. You have we talked about the.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I would love for someone to
ask Nikki Haley to define critical race theory
and also maybe to define wokeness. What she says
is happening in kindergarten is not happening,
period. It's just not happening. And she is
doing the sort of youngin thing where she's
against woke and she's against CRT and she wants
the pledge taught. O Right. But what like what
would be the top tax rate under your presidency? I
don't know. That's policy. I don't deal with that.
One more clip from Nikki Haley's appearance. This
one is about parents rights and schools. It's the
same nonsense that they're now obsessing over.
Speaker 3: Problem is, these school bureaucrats
have decided parents can't do their job. So they
now suddenly think they have to go and infiltrate
everything that they think should be taught to
our kids. We are still the parents. We have to
fight for our kids. We have one job and that's to
make sure that we raise our children to be strong,
faithful, responsible kids. And if we
don't stop all this woke ideology that's
happening in our schools.
Speaker 1: There it.
Speaker 3: Is, we will lose them. And
we can't afford for that to happen.
Speaker 1: The biggest critics of public schools
today have absolutely no idea what is being
taught in public schools. They love to say parents
should have the right to know what their children
are being taught, and yet they have no idea
what's going on in public schools. By the way,
many of them send their kids to private schools or
charter schools anyway. That's a different story
for a different day. This is what the right
is today. Tulsi Talking about abortion after
birth. Nikki Haley talking about woke and CRT. It
draws a crowd, It gets applause. And by the way,
if you can squeeze in a little anti-trans
rhetoric, even more applause. Will anything
turn this around to where the Republican Party
will get back to policy that I disagree with,
but policy, at least I don't know. I don't know
what, if anything, will turn this around. But I'll
be here waiting. And if they ever want to talk
about policy, I'm glad to talk about it with them.